and when I wake up
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the ending of black
panther wakanda forever I I that makes
me uncomfortable the film has a massive
post credit scene that points to a lot
of things in the MCU and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking it all
down it introduces someone new and in
this video we want to talk about the
meaning behind this and also what it
teases for the future there's also
rumors of what we were originally
supposed to be getting and some stuff
with Everett Ross that could set up
secret Invasion sure you can't be
serious if you don't hit that thumbs up
button and if you enjoy the video make
sure you subscribe for spoilers forever
I swear I'm not doing the arm cross
thing and without the way let's get into
wakanda forever
[Music]
No Woman No Cry
healing darling don't shed naughty
No Woman No Cry
okay so upon leaving the theater the
first thing you probably want to see us
talk about is the reveal in the
post-credits scene wakanda forever of
course had to deal with the fact that it
lost its lead due to the sad passing of
Chadwick Boseman Bozeman kept his cancer
a closely guarded secret and the casting
creative team were as shocked as the
rest of the world to learn that he
passed away Ryan coogler has said in
interviews that he originally had a
script in place that focused heavily on
t'challa's perspective but he of course
had to rework this from the ground up
his feeling of grief and losses
massively shaped the release and the
pain of him being gone can be felt in
almost every single performance since
his passing the hashtag recast each
other movement has slowly been building
momentum online with many saying that
the character means a lot to people and
that he should be someone that we still
see in the MCU Marvel has been in a
difficult position because of this and
it's clear they want to honor Chadwick's
Legacy whilst also keeping the Black
Panther in place and we'll check the
comics sure he ends up taking up the
mantle of the Black Panther in the movie
this is something that was passed on to
her in the source material cereal but
the post-credits scene hints how we can
still have it each other in the MCU that
takes over the mantle in the movie we
discovered a child that died of an
unknown illness and since then wakanda
has been mourning the loss Ikea never
attended the funeral not only because
she found it too painful but also
because she was carrying a secret with
her when you lived without saying a word
you did
how you regret not being there with all
of you
it was not easy
he was
King and black panther to everyone
I told me
it was everything now we learned that
she moved to Haiti and we discovered
that she was pregnant with t'challa's
child the mid-credits scene has Nakia
bringing this child to meet Siri and we
learned that his name is t'challa both
she and his father agreed that they
didn't want him being exposed to the
world at this point in his young life
knowing that he would be dying and the
burden of royalty it would add such an
immense pressure to him at this young
age and therefore they hid him away this
is another reason why she didn't go to
the funeral because she would have had
to take him with her and this would have
revealed him they had their own ceremony
for him in Haiti and kept their private
life private so to not draw attention to
him however he is still a principal
conduct and being called to Chala could
cement the strategy that they're going
to be using in the future because of
this we still technically have a
t'challa that can be the Black Panther I
bet this doesn't try and continue or
arrays Chadwick's time in the role
instead it's very much carrying on his
legacy and also allowing the character
of to Charlotte to Don the mantle down
the line I think that shuri will remain
the Black Panther for a number of years
and then we may get a time Jump which
will follow a similar thing to what
happened in Avengers end game this will
allow the character to age up and we
could then have shuri pass the mantle
over to him shuri Burns to Charles robes
at the end of the film and this shows
that she can finally move on movie early
on sets the stage for this with shuri
wanting to set fire to them however she
realized that she'll end up burning the
whole world down if she does and decides
not to on the end of the movie though
she finally does and this is symbolic of
her letting go our cool little detail we
learn is that the baby t'challa has been
going under the name Toussaint this
could actually be another
who was a Haitian General that fought
for the country's Independence that
might be me clutching at straws to try
and connect his name but that's what I
thought that they might have been doing
it's such an emotional scene and it's
very much a Bittersweet way to go
forward with a character in the MCU
originally in the comics t'challa was in
a relationship with storm and the pair
had a son together called as Ry tachola
to choker at the time that black panther
was being developed Disney didn't have
the right to use the X-Men characters
and they set him up with Nakia however
they've now got the characters in the
universe and therefore they can possibly
age up this t'challa and have him be the
one who marries storm in the future of
the MCU he could then have a son and
live out the original plan they had for
Chadwick Boseman without erasing
recasting his version per se so that's
what the post-create scene teases and
after a word from our sponsors I want to
go through what was supposed to be
rumored to be the post-crit scene for
the film now this video is sponsored by
manscaped and to celebrate our American
Chums holiday Tis the time to give
thanks to the manscape performance
package 4.0 it's the perfect package for
your package and inside you'll find the
lawnmower 4.0 there's also the weed
whacker a crop preserver ball deodorant
and the crop Revival ball toner spray
the performance boxer briefs that I'm
wearing right now and this shed travel
bag to help you keep all your goodies
safe the lawnmower 4.0 will make you
want wakanda want Wonder forever why you
didn't pick it up up until now it's got
Advanced Skin safe technology that
massively helps reduce Nicks and cut so
every single shave you're gonna bloody
love it it also has a 4000k LED light
that looks like iron Hearts reactor and
it's waterproof as well the weed whacker
yeah it's been a complete Lifesaver as
I'm getting a bit older now I've started
getting ear hairs start getting nose
hairs and this has massively helped me
keep my grooming in check we also have
the crop preserver ball deodorant and
the crop reviver ball toner spray that
will make it infinity stone smell great
manscaped also just launched two new
shower products and this is the refined
body wash I'll keep you hydrated and
make your skin feel great like my man no
more now more will you wonder about how
you smell as they've also just launched
a signature deodorant as well so treat
yourself or a loved one this November
with a manscape performance package 4.0
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code heavy spoilers at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code heavy spoilers at manscape.com be
thankful this season for the best gift
from manscaped your balls well thank you
cheers now after the death of t'challa
around his funeral the film moves to
like Belle's character looking for
vibranium this is part of a
government-funded Expedition that ends
up causing issues with wakanda and the
UN now when the movie was in production
there were leaks that it would be
revealed she was hired by Dr Doom in the
post-credits scene this has since been
debunked with Marvel stating that no
scene was ever filmed where there
actually was part of the planetar is
something we'll never know but I can say
with 100 certainty that Doctor Doom was
gonna be in the [ __ ]
now so what happened was a couple of
months back there was a post on Reddit
that had major leaks for both wakanda
forever and Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania we now know due to the release
that about 90 of these leaks were right
and they did mention Dr Doom at the end
of the post so it kind of lends weight
to it being true but it could also be
entirely made up either way I thought
I'd just dropped that in there and we
can go back to the whole Tom Cruise Iron
Man Saga again he was he was in it it
was in it
now Marvel kinda have a lot on their
play at the moment with Kang so it makes
sense he just focus on him for the
upcoming phases rather than trying to
shove other villains in the mix
personally I'm glad that the film just
stuck with the one credit scene as I
think the movie works better not ending
with the audience has been like oh my
God there's a big villain for the next
movie instead wakanda forever has a more
reflective introspective and
acknowledgment of Chadwick Boseman
rather than trying to Hype up the next
big movie this keeps the focus on him
and also his character d'challa rather
than having morbius show up or something
and tell everyone that it's intriguing
now either way in the movie The Tallow
Canyons attack and they discover that
the government has managed to get hold
of a device that can locate vibranium no
more is desperate to get this as he
knows it could potentially give those
who have the mineral the power to
enslave the planet this throws Riri into
the mix who we learn created the device
capable of locating the medal she has
the ironheart's suit early in its stages
and she develops one that will like be
in her Disney Plus show it also seems
like there's a bigger and bulkier
version of this and though details are
sketchy we have had some behind the
scenes shots that show where things
could be heading she does get her
Beetleborg one in this which I think
will be the Mainstay suit whilst this
one in the leaks is used for specific
jobs Anthony Ramos will be playing the
hood in the series and there's even
rumors that we might get Mephisto
he hears some some crazy things
sometimes crazy and true can't be unless
anyway in the comics the hood is a man
named Parker Robbins who came across a
demon this was like a retcon to be door
Mamu and Parker managed to kill him he
stole a magical clock that the villain
was carrying and this gave him special
abilities slowly he started to take over
the entire crime syndicate and I think
Riri will very much be trying to stop
this from happening
all my life
to pay the price
[Music]
[Applause]
either way the government is after Riri
too leading to a big fight that the
telekines also get involved in and the
final thing I want to talk about is the
reveal with the lovebirds Everett Ross
and Val turns out they were married and
it's a big addition that's actually a
pretty crazy reveal in the film we
discover that he's been giving Intel to
wakanda and his ex-wife has him arrested
after Amanda's death at the end of the
movie he's broken out of prison by Akai
and we know they'll be featuring in
secret invasion next he's going
incognito in that trailer and also
working with Nick Fury so he'll likely
be on the side trying to oust the hidden
Scrolls and the government while
interestingly connects with secret
Invasion as well and then the bucket was
revealed that a scroll was masquerading
as her it was hero Nick Fury that were
getting it on and after she tried to
kill him Fury 4 back he managed to kill
her which is when it was revealed that
she was actually a shapeshifter this is
what clued him into the invasion and
potentially they've switched things up
with rossier to make it so that he's the
person who discovers it Ross is busted
out of jail
and she's now wearing a new suit she was
kicked out of the door of melange
earlier in the movie and though she gets
to be back in them she's now more in
line with the midnight Angels this was a
team that ended up being created in the
source material and this all happened
after the Dora melange members fractured
off and formed their own group now we
also know that Val is gonna be creating
the Thunderbolts and that she'll lead
the group in the MCU we have a lineup of
them from d23 however in addition to
this I've heard Abomination will also be
part of the group they haven't made that
official yet due to She-Hulk but that
makes the most sense because at the
moment the the entire team's just people
now take that with a pinch of salt yeah
but that's releasing as the last movie
in Phase five so we have time to play
the secret Invasion thing out and for
her to form the team in case you don't
know but basically Marvel's answer to
the suicide squad and though this group
of Misfits isn't brought up here I feel
like they're slowly slotting valve
throughout the MCU to to tease towards
that coming General Ross will also be
played by Harrison Ford board and I've
got a feeling that it's gonna be a
really big movie now all in all these
are the threads that I can be seeing
used in the future of the MCU though we
haven't had a Dora melange on midnight
Angels Disney Plus show confirmed yet
there have been rumors of one happening
for a long time I think this would be
the perfect way to flesh out the world
of wakanda and I hope that we get
summing along those lines so those are
all the main things that I can see
happening in the future of the MCU based
off what happens at the end and the
little breadcrumbs they give us next we
go to the Iron Heart show with Riri
Williams taking on the hood let me know
if you're excited to see what happens in
that and I'd also love to hear your
thoughts on the film as well as its
ending we will be doing a bigger spoiler
breakdown of the movie going over more
of the characters and Flash just a
better video so yeah make sure you stay
locked into the channel for that we are
in competition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of November and all you have to do
to be when the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the end
credit scene we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on Twitter heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch make sure you
check out our Brighton of the leaks of
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania which
will be linked on screen right now lots
of things to talk about about Kang so
yeah hopefully you see over there right
after this now the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace
thank you